all right welcome to [ __ ] back I don't
know even know if it's been like a
second or and day uh Wow
and I go in here the [ __ ] thing was
like and I have no idea where to go
there's like dead n7 from there we go
there's like that ants every every
[ __ ] we're sorry so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna no [ __ ] boxes and [ __ ]
you got a problem with that of course it
does
they sink
of [ __ ] a taste
man epical thing right there FBI that
I'm actually it's not a tanto [ __ ] is
coming
[Music]
things I can't pull these for whatever
reason
I can do a little like it but it's like
they're nothing nothing
come on
shut up no one likes you
I apparently need a key to be out there
[ __ ] great [ __ ] you ah I so mean so
cold and heartless I'm doing the Box way
now no that's not the Box way cry
whoa
sorry about that dude I hate you so much
oh [ __ ] I don't want to carry on I hate
this [ __ ] part where do I find the
key I don't [ __ ] know where's it
there it is it's gotta be something
what my walking backwards
ah correct
big meanie what it is is there something
there I got a see crap there's nothing
there and you're there good before you
roll I'm just gonna use my box jump and
pretend that three sixes and [ __ ] while
we are in the water no problem
got a look in here
better take the safe route you know oh
that's pretty sweet flick brah see my
rep I'm sorry Oh
come on oh come on oh come on one day
there's only boxes in here why with why
is just fantastic
I don't know where to go I don't know
what to do I didn't even know what I'm
doing
ah don't you dare don't you dare
[Music]
I'm even going
what about here nope
here what
it gets through the door right
Kravis freakiest out
now I know [ __ ]
[Music]
I don't know what to do why do you hate
me so much he's right there Disney yep
I'm just chillin on my box crap
oh maybe there's something in the closet
ah wait
I'm standing on the box bro I'm standing
on the box
standing on the box no problem I'm not
signing on the box I have one little box
okay you'd better be [ __ ] something
in there Oh
Beryl is that a key okay now we just
gotta run okay if I could do it go
before he comes after me
I don't like and he comes after me I've
got a key
why can't you see you go up go down I
mean huh I mean down down down
ya know now
oh man I gotta sneeze coming
come on there's God man that sucks for
me it's so large
you best be joking man maybe that's for
the best
at least the monsters in the air you
gotta be optimistic in times like these
seriously though
okay let's try every [ __ ] combination
there is I like going the same here in
the dog thank you for all the clues game
I hate you too
this might take a while I should go get
popcorn if I were you or something I
don't know maybe maybe professions I
don't know I wanted to try it all off so
I guess two down
holy [ __ ] I'm a genius
I knew that I knew that was the right
kind of combination what do you think
I'll stick with
I could have stupid that's what I'm
going it's gotta be this one that sweet
stairs stairs [ __ ] you wanna monster but
we collected nothing and we're back well
that's this fantastic
maybe mambro's up here now or something
I don't offer yeah they're all lit now
see how did something blue seems I
should wait
nothing scary happens whoa inception
music really
dramatic slow-mo walk right
right
when
inception it's like leaning in [ __ ]
you did
I wanted you escape now my friends will
eat your brain you did
epic school sorry bro your dad whoa that
was really [ __ ] creepy
you're like kiss my face
or or is it the end
zombie skate part two sex act okay
thank you for watching zombies Gabe I
[ __ ] did it I did it myself too I
don't have to cheat or anything except
the bookshelf part but that was [ __ ]
up anyway
I hope you enjoyed bye bye